Turns out, the man most famous for playing
the wizarding world's nastiest teacher was
also a dedicated friend, a mentor, and an
enormous amount of fun to be around.
Who’d have guessed it?
Alan Rickman might be gone, but he left us
a lot to think about and a lot to take as
inspiration.
In January 2016, Rickman died of pancreatic
cancer.
At 69, he was no spring chicken but he wasn’t
particularly old, either.
Fans around the world mourned both the untimely
nature of his passing and its seeming suddenness.
Had anyone known he was sick?
How long had he been suffering, and how severely?
Had it been publicized?
How could one beloved man's passing, in an
age of such unprecedented interconnectivity,
so shock the entire world?
Simply put: it was a secret.
The first new thing the world learned about
Alan Rickman upon his death was that he had
been battling pancreatic cancer for a few
months prior, after being diagnosed in August
following a small stroke.
Pancreatic cancer, sometimes called a "silent
cancer," takes time to present any symptoms,
and is often found after a seemingly unconnected
problem surfaces.
Rickman decided to keep the news confined
to close friends and family, and soldiered
on with his work.
As it happened, no one knew what they were
going to lose until he was already gone.
Though Rickman portrayed many noteworthy characters,
Severus Snape Harry Potter's grouchy potions
professor might be the most memorable of all.
Snape is vindictive, moody, and even in his
moments of bravery, deeply and unrelentingly
cynical.
It's a fine edge to dance upon, but Rickman
made it look easy.
For eight films, he portrayed Snape with caustic
aplomb, and that performance has become nothing
less than iconic.
“That is the second time you’ve spoken
out of turn Ms. Granger are you incapable
of restraining yourself or do you take pride
in being an insufferable know it all?”
“He’s got a point, you know.”
By all accounts, it was also the role that
had the least to do with his actual personality.
When remembering the actor posthumously, colleagues
and friends have repeatedly touched upon his
unrelenting kindness and generosity of spirit.
In a tribute for Entertainment Weekly, Kate
Winslet mused:
"If there was one word I could use to really
describe Al, it would be kind.
He was so kind… whenever Al would go out
to supper and anyone else would try and pay,
he would somehow have phoned ahead or slipped
his credit card ahead of the meal so no one
even got a look at the check."
Tales of helping hands, thoughtful gifts,
and general friendliness seem to surround
Rickman’s legacy.
He wasn't just passively kind but actively
generous which is about as far from Snape
as you can get.
Younger fans will never know how heated the
debate over Snape's true loyalties grew back
when the Harry Potter saga was still a work
in progress.
Snape's motivations were murky and his actions
ambiguous until the very end, when it was
finally revealed that he was on the side of
the angels all along, motivated by his deep
and lasting love for Harry's mother Lily.
Though some had guessed, no one knew the full
truth for sure until the story’s very final
chapters.
No one, that is, except Alan Rickman.
It's since come to light that author J.K.
Rowling told Rickman the truth about Snape's
motivations years earlier to help inform his
performance.
According to Rowling, what she told him boiled
down to just one word:
“Always.”
If you revisit the Potter films, this knowledge
will become more readily apparent in Rickman's
performance: although he is sour, unrelentingly
harsh, and sometimes even outright cruel,
he returns, over and over again, to the side
of light and love.
His anger at Harry appears so much more nuanced
than at first glance, and his frustration
with the growing darkness around him more
pronounced.
Snape was always much more than he seemed,
and Rickman made that apparent in everything
from overt declarations of loyalty to the
subtlest, most fleeting glances.
Though Rickman's trademark style and double-bass
voice made every role he took on memorable
in its own right, arguably one of his best
was Alexander Dane in 1999’s Galaxy Quest.
Also an actor, the character of Dane feels
degraded by his role as Dr. Lazarus on the
in-universe Star-Trek-equivalent Galaxy Quest,
which requires the use of a complicated and
silly-looking skull prosthetic as well as
a horde of alien catchphrases.
“By Grabthar’s hammer… what a savings.”
Galaxy Quest became an instant cult hit, and
is often hailed in Star Trek fandom as a better
Trek movie than some of the official outings.
Rickman's performance in particular, of course,
is held to be one of the film's most memorable.
So it’s probably no surprise to find that
a sequel was in the works, which was kept
totally under wraps until Rickman’s tragic
passing put an end to the project.
It's a bittersweet turn of events that acts
as both a testament to Rickman's acting and
a sad reminder of what could have been.
There are few relationships in the Harry Potter
series more charged and complex than the one
between Harry and Snape.
After all, Harry Potter and the Half-Blood
Prince pretty much translates as "Harry Potter
and Severus Snape”.
Snape basically gives his life to protect
Harry, yet bullies him relentlessly for years.
Meanwhile, Harry loathes Snape to the point
of obsession yet ends up naming a son after
him.
Their relationship sits at the heart of the
series and the crux of Harry’s journey.
It's only appropriate, then, that Alan Rickman
matters so deeply to Daniel Radcliffe.
In a Facebook post made after Rickman’s
death, Radcliffe hailed him as one of the
greatest actors he would ever work with.
He continued:
“He is also one of the loyalest and most
supportive people I've ever met in the film
industry."
Radcliffe went on to detail Rickman's kindness
and generosity, his mastery of the craft of
acting, and his wit, adding one particularly
heart-wrenching detail:
"I'm pretty sure he came and saw everything
I ever did on stage both in London and New
York."
Rickman's dedication to performance was legendary
but it was easily surpassed by his devotion
to his fellow performers.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.